[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti allora spiega un
attimo come mai sono sparite in aula e
sono andata in calabria in realtà mi
sono sposata molto presto a 19 anni ho
avuto la mia prima bambina mi sono
sposata ragazzo calabrese e quindi
teatro gran parte della mia vita della
mia gioventù a fare la mamma e questa
cosa mi è servita moltissimo per la mia
attività
dopo cioè giallozafferano perché ho
iniziato a cucinare prestissimo un po
perché dovevano e quindi ho fatto di
necessità virtù poi visto che mi piaceva
tantissimo è vero che io vengo da una
famiglia di ristoratori e quindi anche
lì devo dire sono un pò nata in cucina
andava un po sbirciare quello che faceva
mio papà anche quello che faceva lo chef
che ogni volta che mi giravo ingrediente
segreto per non farsi ma poi quando ho
capito come funzionava aggirato
l'ostacolo e quindi anche in quel caso
devo dire
diciamo la cucina è nata con me diciamo
perché piccolina al papa con appunto al
ristorante la nonna austriaca che ci ha
cresciuto che era bravissima in cucina
io ero la più piccola quindi la seguivo
in tutte le sue
evoluzioni in cucina e quindi ci sono
sono cresciuta con la cucina nel sangue
un po per queste cose
il fatto di essere stata tanti anni però
anche in campania mi ha permesso di
venire in contatto con le materie prime
con la natura di toccare veramente con
mano quello che era il cibo e la sua
trasformazione vederlo anche piantare
non so il pomodoro crescere raccoglierlo
trasformarlo che sia stata una cosa che
mi ha molto molto aiutata devo dire a
capire un po anche quello che era le
esigenze o in cucina
e a proposito di onde visto appunto
pesto prima è un po il filo conduttore
devo dire che nel 2006 quando io e il
mio compagno ci siamo affacciati sul
mondo della cucina nel web c'era la
calma piatta nel senso che l'unica cosa
che si trovava era
sì un web molto testuale privo di
fotografie e voi sapete che tv si mangia
prima con gli occhi è molto molto noioso
e si ricercava veramente un qualcosa che
potesse attirare anche avvicinare alla
cucina e non era certo la scrittura in
italiano è abituato a leggere molto poco
e si scoccia anche molto lo vediamo
anche dalle mail nostri a me li avete
una mail chilometrica magari lasciate un
attimo per ultima e poi vela dimenticate
se c'è scritto due righe la leggete
sicuramente per capire vi dicono in modo
molto veloce quindi dalla calma piatta
abbiamo pensato di tirar fuori qualcosa
che potesse essere un po più mosso no le
fotografie le immagini quindi in quel
momento quello che secondo noi cava non
era certo la cucina è già esisteva ma
era proprio qualcosa che invitasse e che
aiutasse le persone ad avvicinarsi alla
cucina anche perché forse molti di voi
erroneamente credono agli italiani cui
ci sono tutti bene non è vero sono gli
italiani mangiano molto bene ma non
sanno tutti cucinare poi c'è da dire che
c'è stato anche un gadget e razionale
perché per esempio tante mamme quelle
della mia età sono state donne in
carriera e quindi non hanno potuto
trasmettere tantissimo la cucina alle
figlie e quindi le figlie come hanno
cominciato a cucinare con giallo
zafferano ma era era ovvio era un mezzo
molto giovane erano video erano foto
quindi erano immagini che avvicinavano
invogliavano le persone guardavano un
video guardavano le fotografie di ce
vole massi ce la posso fare
addirittura una volta c'è stata una
giornalista giapponese che mi ha detto
in giappone noi guardiamo
giallozafferano perché ci sono tante
immagini e quindi lo scoglio della
lingua per noi esiste poco perché
capiamo dalle immagini cosa dobbiamo
fare
quindi pensate un po quanto l'immagine e
i video sono importanti no abbattono
tantissime barriere e credo che questo
unito al fatto della semplicità di
utilizzo quindi per spiegare le ricette
passo per passo non dare mai
assolutamente niente per scontato
questo credo nella cui mente altri campi
sia una chiave perché è proprio grazie a
questo sistema quindi di avvicinamento
delle persone con le immagini video e
soprattutto essendo tutoriali che noi in
di giallozafferano abbiamo avuto questo
grande
successi parlo ancora come se fossi lì
in realtà non sono più giallo zafferano
da tre anni ma è una mia creatura e
quindi per me sarà sempre parte appunto
di me questo diciamo che è nato in tempi
in cui non era molto capito dalle
aziende nel 2006 era un po come il
paleolitico nel senso c'eravamo noi con
tanta speranza agli utenti che ci
venivano molto dietro e che gradivano
molto il nostro contenuto e quello che
facevamo ma le aziende non investivano e
questo è stato il nostro problema per i
primi tre anni perché vedevamo appunto
che gli utenti crescevano
esponenzialmente ci seguivano un sacco
di commenti e gli apprezzamenti e quindi
ne eravamo molto carichi sapevamo di
essere sulla strada giusta ma non
arrivavano i soldi questa è la grande
problema po come quando sei troppo
avanti le cose e come essere un po
indietro no finché appunto il tuo
ecosistema non si abitua e capisce
l'importanza che che a quello che stai
facendo
in realtà noi siamo andati avanti così
dal 2006 appunto al 2009
e poi c'è stato diciamo l'avvento dei
social cioè l'utilizzo diciamo massivo
dei social cominciato più o meno 2008
2009 in in italia e quello ci ha
permesso di fare un salto perché perché
mentre prima allo zafferano lo
conoscevano tutti come brand poi a un
certo punto abbiamo detto sì ma i sogni
anche vicino alla ricetta di giallo
zafferano e ovviamente una persona si
utilizza molto meglio che un brand
ovviamente io ero davvero io a cucinare
quindi si è creato questa sorta di
legame con l'utente perché l'utente si
rivedeva in me perché io ero la vicina
di casa era quello che magari speravano
tutti di avere una vicina di casa da cui
poter correre chiedere un consiglio
questa è sicuramente stata l'arma
vincente
d'altra parte dobbiamo dire che in
questi anni appunto in cui non
riuscivamo a tirar soldi in barca la
motivazione del nostro team è stata la
cosa che ci ha permesso di andare avanti
e di creare questi contenuti
se c'è stata una cosa su cui io sono
sempre stata fissata era la qualità del
contenuto devo dire che a volte
ci siamo un po scoraggiati perché perché
il lavoro di giallozafferano
sostanzialmente era un lavoro piuttosto
caro a livello editoriale perché noi
avevamo appunto le persone che
inserivano nel sito
le ricette avevamo chi cucinava io ma
poi ovviamente anche altre persone
avevamo i fotografi avevamo la parte dei
soci giallozafferano era una macchina
molto complessa che generava sicuramente
un contenuto di qualità ma all'epoca
c'erano i forum ancora i forum che erano
fatti da centinaia di persone che
portavano appunto gratuitamente
ovviamente il contenuto e lì era insomma
un gioco molto molto facile gestire un
forum nov
ogni personalmente un contenuto
gratuitamente io sono il padrone del
forum faccio poco o niente se non
moderare ovviamente nel corso del tempo
il forum come sapete andato scemando
perché i soci hanno preso l'avvento
erano molto più intuitivi molto più
veloci e devo dire che alla lunga il
contenuto di qualità ha pagato io
continuo a credere che i contenuti di
qualità alla lunga paghi non sono
convinta di questo perché nonostante ci
siano corsi e ricorsi mode
che spesso anche demonizzano il
contenuto di qualità sembra quasi che se
una persona in un momento abbia l'idea
geniale che vi costa zero possa avere un
grandissimo successo però magari ce l'ha
in quell'anno
l'anno dopo magari sparisce questa è
anche da dire che ha un contenuto un
contenuto buono e di qualità magari fa
più fatica però secondo me può può
perdurare nel tempo perché alle spalle a
qualcosa
quindi abbiamo motivato moltissimo i
nostri i nostri diciamo collaboratori
all'epoca e siamo riusciti poi a un
certo punto ad avere un sostegno
economico ci hanno dato mi ricordo del
2009 50 mila euro 50.000 euro per però
cosa dovevamo fare con quei soldi
dovevamo camparci un anno pagando le
persone pagando il lo spazio e noi
diciamo che dal tavolo della cucina di
casa mia dove abbiamo creato
giallozafferano abbiamo in quel momento
siamo riusciti ad avere la prima sede
quindi una sede qualche devo dire
macchinario in più all'epoca dovevamo
fare delle foto all'epoca tutto costava
molto non era come oggi con gli
smartphone ei tablet che si fanno delle
foto meravigliosi dove avere una reflex
insomma c'era un importante investimento
anche tecnologico da fare computer per
le persone che doveva lavorare con noi
quindi anche quell'anno quindi il quarto
anno è stato abbastanza difficoltoso
perché noi ovviamente non ci siamo dati
lo stipendio per un altro anno perché
volevamo appunto prendere delle persone
che ci aiutassero quindi dei dipendenti
però devo dire che dal da lì in poi le
aziende hanno cominciato a capire il
valore del web ovviamente a darci
qualche soddisfazione in più e quindi da
lì in poi è stato tutta una salita però
quello che voglio dire è che non esiste
quasi mai una start up senza difficoltà
senza diciamo un team da motivare
per noi quello che è stato fondamentale
come vi dicevo prima è stato il
contenuto di qualità
un team da trattare non bene ma di più
da motivare e soprattutto una continuità
questa è un'altra cosa secondo me è
fondamentale il contenuto deve avere una
continuità nel tempo non puoi fare un
contenuto oggi aspettare un mese per
farne un altro ma quello che serve è
continuità anche nei contenuti
queste sono state un po le nostre
caratteristiche anche il fatto di non
deludere mai l'utente per noi era molto
importante cioè lavorare veramente
perché l'utente fosse contento di quello
che noi facevamo quindi a volte anche
lasciare da parte certe aziende perché
magari non erano coerenti con il nostro
modo di lavorare
ovviamente non puoi piacere a tutti però
non puoi neanche lavorare con tutti
secondo noi parlo sempre noi perché
permettere lo zafferano ma ancora sono
peronaci punto it è un team di persone
di cui io sono oppure la frontwoman però
è sempre fatto da appunto da più persone
e quindi questa è stata un po la nostra
filosofia nel tempo la cosa è andata
molto bene perché noi stiamo forse è
stato stati gli unici a passare dal web
a tutti gli altri media in poco tempo
perché da lì a poco ci ha contattato per
esempio mondadori ci ha chiesto di voler
fare un libro in realtà i nostri utenti
ci avevano già chiesto molte volte di
fare un libro ma non era ovviamente il
nostro focus molto concentrati sul sul
digitale quindi non era il nostro campo
con loro abbiamo fatto anche il libro è
stato un grandissimo successo e poi da
lì in poi abbiamo ne abbiamo fatti altri
nel tempo è arrivata anche la
televisione in realtà e anche lì devo
dire che è stato un altro grande
successo però quello che abbiamo cercato
sempre di fare noi è sempre stato in
ogni mezzo appunto di rappresentare
quello che veramente eravamo è stato
anche una bella lotta perché sia con i
libri che con la televisione abbiamo
dovuto lottare molto per cercare di far
capire che volevamo mantenere la nostra
identità lottare per la propria identità
secondo me è importantissimo perché è
vero che il mondo cambia e quindi magari
deve cambiare il modo di comunicare
l'esempio è adesso adesso si è spostato
un po tutto no qui social sono la cosa
molto importante su cui lavorare
però anche lì non bisogna perdere la
propria personalità secondo me anche
perché le persone lo avvertono quando si
fanno delle contenuti o si fanno azioni
che non sono proprio nostre bisogna
cercare appunto di cambiare ma di
rimanere sempre fedeli a quello che è il
nostro contenuto della nostra
personalità perché le persone
soprattutto adesso vogliono emozionalità
vogliono il vero personaggio sempre di
più adesso devo dire quindi questo è
stato un po il il nostro percorso in
giallo zafferano per un certo punto un
po si è interrotto il feeling tra me
giallo ovviamente noi nel frattempo
eravamo stati appunto acquisiti da
banzai che era questo web editor inc che
ha creduto per prima in italia nel web e
in tutti quelli che facevano contenuti
per il web
però ovviamente li son cambiate un po
poi parametri io continuavo a condurre
ea dirigere giallozafferano però c'erano
altre priorità ovviamente i tempi
cambiavano et noire non avevamo sempre
molto chiusi dentro le quattro mura
appunto di giallozafferano io sentivo
invece molto l'esigenza di andare verso
l'esterno anche perché si cominciava a
ad aver bisogno di persone che uscissero
dalla loro realtà e portassero alla loro
realtà al di fuori delle quattro mura
questa è una cosa insomma che non
iniziava la mia azienda quindi un certo
punto
noi ci siamo anche quotati in borsa come
gruppo banzai di cui appunto
giallozafferano faceva parte di visto un
po cambiate tutte tutti gli assetti
bisognava lavorare molto per i numeri un
po di meno per il contenuto e io non mi
ritrovavo più in quel mondo non lo
sentivo più mio
io da lì a poco sarei diventata
dirigente di giallo zafferano
ma non era quello che volevo io ho
sempre detto ai miei superiori che non
volevo essere un manager ma volevo
essere un imprenditore imprenditrice di
me stessa soprattutto e non era più
quello il posto quindi ho lasciato
giallozafferano sapendo che poteva
tranquillamente continuare anche senza
di me
eravamo diventati il 30 nel frattempo è
iniziato in due o tre e mi sono dedicata
a sonia peronaci puntoit pensando però
già
uno spazio eventi io ho lavorato per un
anno a casa mia perché cercava uno
spazio dove poter incontrare la gente
che è un po quello che mi era mancato in
giallo zafferano
e vero che erano tempi diversi e
all'epoca lavorava molto sui contenuti
per il sito poi dei social è cambiato
tutto quindi più emozionalità più
persone che vanno in esterna più persone
che raggiungono altre persone almeno
questo era quello che a noi mancava a me
mancava quindi abbiamo trovato una
relazione molto bella di lì abbiamo
pensato appunto a un posto anche dove
poter
avere delle persone che arrivano a
trovarti o spazi denti abbiamo fatto
scuola di cucina quindi proprio un posto
diverso dove potersi anche vedere no e
non soltanto tramite web
ma proprio incontrare ovviamente quello
che abbiamo fatto
appena usciti da giallo zafferano e
andare a parlare con tutti i centri
media con tutte le aziende dicendo noi
non facciamo più pubblicità tabellare
sul mio sito sappiatelo quindi pensavo
mi chiuderanno porte in faccia e vi
diranno che sei venuto invece questa
scelta coraggiosa perché andare in un
centro mila e dire che non vogliamo fare
più tabellare e a quell'epoca era un po
azzardato invece ci hanno risposto oh
finalmente uno che sta cambiando
qualcosa
quindi per noi che
che abbiamo veramente preso questa
decisione perché era che sentivamo io
odiavo andare su giallo zafferano e
dover chiudere 24 posizioni
pubblicitarie con la di block era una
cosa che mi mandava in bestia perché una
persona deve poter fruire di un
contenuto liberamente pensavo ci sarà un
altro modo per riuscire appunto a terra
sulla pubblicità senza rompere le
scatole a chi viene a vedere il
contenuto
ci siamo inventati una serie di cose per
esempio una cosa che è piaciuta
tantissimo sono stati netiv cioè
raccontare le aziende è una cosa che
dobbiamo fare spessissimo in america e
che in italia invece si fa molto poco e
in italia ci sono delle realtà
bellissime che durano 40 50 70 anni
familiari che oltre a raccontare
l'azienda quando centri ti rendi conto
che proprio bello raccontare la famiglia
e quello che c'è stato dietro questa
azienda ed è un po ritornare
all'emozionalità quello che va
moltissimo oggi anche questa è stata una
cosa molto bella che abbiamo proposto ed
è stata accettata ma siamo stati tra i
primi parlo perché pensavamo che era
questo che la persona che la gente
volevano oltre oltre a capire il
prodotto capire chi lo crea va al
prodotto abbiamo scoperto delle cose
meravigliose
abbiamo fatto tantissimi netiv e devo
dire che
sempre di più l'italia si sta aprendo
questo tipo di esperienze credo che
questa sia la strada quindi come lo
faccio io con il cibo
penso che sia una cosa che si possa fare
con tutte le altre materie di cui
appunto vi occupiate l'importante
secondo me è anche sentire di voler
cambiare no quando voi avete questa
questa fiamma questo fuoco dentro come
ce l'ho io che non mi sento più bene a
un certo punto a fare sempre le stesse
cose
quello è il momento in cui bisogna
cambiare per se stessi ma penso anche
per le persone perché come siete stufi
voi di determinate cose probabilmente
anche il pubblico ha bisogno di cose
nuove di cose nuove che magari voi già
sentite ma che non sapete non tirate
fuori per paura perché così fan tutti
a volte dire io voglio cambiare voglio
fare qualcosa di diverso e proprio
quella cosa che vi fa fare il salto di
qualità e fa dire alla persona con cui
state parlando o finalmente qualcuno
l'ha pensato quindi anche le paure che
una persona ha a volte no di tirar fuori
quello che in realtà è un esigenza
personale è sbagliato perché magari
questa esigenza come voi ce l'hanno
tantissime altre persone
e bello parlare delle proprie esperienze
ma anche dei propri fallimenti
perché sempre di più ci rendiamo persone
normali non esistono supereroi non
esistono fenomeni anche se ce l'hanno
fatto credere per tantissimi anni
ovunque io credo che siamo tutti uguali
abbiamo tutti bisogno delle stesse cose
e soprattutto abbiamo bisogno di
confrontarci di far capire anche quando
parliamo perché è umano e può capitare a
tutti abbiamo visto anche le persone più
importanti quindi il mio messaggio è
sempre quello di spronare le persone a
tirar fuori quello che veramente il loro
desiderio più più più intimo perché ci
sono queste persone e secondo me è
proprio bello condividere tutto quello
che una persona dentro perché così si
riesce a tirar fuori qualcosa ea fare
qualcosa di bello ed innovativo quindi
senza paura
[Applauso]
[Musica]